JJ what is something wrong no nothing is
ever wrong here that's why we're gonna
fight hard to save your Diner now you
said your new landlord didn't give you a
chance to counter
who is it it was a company with a weird
sounding name
was it Putin
Voldemort Putin
of Russia I'd love to take that bastard
down no no
sorry Ron doors are locked we've taken
your key cards and your phones and the
automatic timer won't go off until
tomorrow at 8 A.M you're trapped in
there we tell it security not to disturb
you under any circumstances and the
phone's internet oh they've been
disconnected and I left the rusty
hacksaw on the table so the first person
who hacks their face off gets released
that's not what is that true guys this
is insane okay let us out oh my God babe
Game of Thrones is on tonight it's the
series finale Khaleesi is marrying Jack
Sparrow
oh God that show has really gone off the
rails look it makes sense if you've read
the books what powers this what gives us
the tools to attain our goals face our
fears take that next step into the
unknown it's energy
Verizon Exxon and chipotle are proud to
announce a cross-platform merger of our
three great Brands whether it's
extending your 6G coverage drilling
natural gas out of shale or perfecting
the chicken quesadilla we will give you
the energy to get you to the next level
and with enough energy America nothing
can stop us the all-new Verizon Chipotle
Exxon proud to be one of America's eight
companies
yeah I think you're really going to like
it here and obviously everyone's in a
really great mood now because of the
Cubs winning the series yeah it seems
really nice I mean I am going to miss
Pawnee though my grandmother lived in
Pawnee for 60 years and
I want to put her ashes in the Time
Capsule my cat turnip was the greatest
cat ever and I'd like to put his ashes
in the Time Capsule for the last time
and I won't say this again
there will be no human or feline ashes
in either one of the time capsules
except for turnip except for turnips no
chanting look we don't know what the
world is going to be like in 50 years we
we could all have been wiped out from
disease or the flu so what's your
suggestion
I don't know
I'm just scared this is a nice house you
say that every time we're here I'm just
trying to distract you so you don't have
a nervous breakdown I think I am past
that point you don't have to worry about
me anymore hey folks welcome back great
to have so many good friends and
colleagues we're looking forward to a
great conversation and a good dinner as
usual there's only
only Optics you're gonna have to wait
until after dinner I'm looking at you
Leslie okay well as long as we get to
play charades later
okay last time we played charades he
spent three and a half hours here you're
just mad because you lost oh come on
I can't speak of the future
but I will the future of Pawnee will
involve us flying around in space taxis
where we will communicate on watches
and blink our feelings to each other
rather than use words let the
filibustering begin I would now like to
share some ideas I have for JJ Abrams
seventh chapter in the Star Wars saga
pan down from the Twin sons of Tatooine
we are now close on the mouth of the
sarlacc pit after a beat the gloved
Mandalorian armor Gauntlet of Boba Fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and the feared Bounty Hunter pulls
himself from the maw of the sand Beast
if he holds the reality gem that means
he can jump from different realities
this will be our link to the Marvel
Universe from the Star Wars universe
we need to talk
what is that this is a flying robot I
just shot out of the sky after it
delivered a package to my house I
thought you didn't like to pass judgment
on the package was addressed to my son
who was four years old
and does not own a Grizzle doodad
somehow the robots looked at Diane's
computer and learned something about my
child and then brought him a box of
presents so I destroyed the robot No One
Is Safe from these bastards tell me what
to do Leslie
I want to help you take them down
oh Baby that feels amazing but I'm sorry
I'm gonna have to go I have to meet Rick
and TC at the King Kamehameha Club
Higgins is missing Dennis Feinstein what
who's that my name is Jonathan karate we
need to talk we'll make it quick I gotta
go pull the plug on my dad in 10 minutes
I'm now going to open one of these 10
envelopes at random
to determine your simulated disaster
funny has been hit by
a strain of avian flu yes avian blue
jackpot can you hear
oh Leslie you on a TV well you're on
mine Brett we're having a video
conference oh okay Pawnee has been hit
with the avian flu
no this is bad news I need everyone
there at Animal Control to eradicate all
the infected birds in town kill all
birds this is for the drill right yes
but I'm actually gonna kill these Birds
for real no no just pretend right right
so how do I kill him like with a gun no
I can fill up a bathtub and just drown
them one at a time okay let's forget we
ever talked got it kill him okay
casualty update only four dead two of
whom were already Gravely ill and
brothers that family took a terrible hit
let's go news not so fast I regret to
inform you that someone in this room has
begun exhibiting symptoms Christopher
Traeger
a few months ago the thought of an
infectious disease even hypothetical
would have sent me careening towards
bummerville but now
I am infected with the killer virus
and I feel fine
therapy
highly irregular we have followed
protocol to the letter no you did not
unfortunately no one contacted the
transit Department to shut down bus
service so you wrote a bus with a
contagious man and he infected you and
39 others that is impossible I do not
ride the bus I ride my bicycle behind a
bus as a Windbreak doesn't matter
prepare for the diarrhea okay who
with Transit
my bad guys that's my bad Chris very
sorry damn it Jam should had Animal
Control kill you oh who you want me to
kill no one I'll kill him as soon as I'm
done with these birds
well the first thing I'm gonna do is say
sorry I'm sorry
that the spotlight is on me and not on
Ben because he is going to make a great
Congressman second the mailman where are
you ah you're ridiculous and men's
rights is nothing third I'm now going to
give you permanent answers to all the
silly questions that you're going to end
up asking me and every other woman in
this election over the next few months
why did I change my hairstyle I don't
know I just thought it would look better
or my kids got gum in it are you trying
to have it all that question makes no
sense it's a stupid question stop asking
it don't ask it do you miss your kids
while you're at work yes of course I do
everybody does
you know sometimes I don't I do have one
question
hold on oh my God I'm kidding sorry Andy
are you getting sick it's flu season
again and I cannot get sick stock up on
Kleenex don't touch your face don't
touch anything people are dropping like
flies we already have to quarantine
Larry Leslie I don't feel good can I
just work from home the tent is your
home now Larry we already forwarded your
mail
it